we have literally just uh agreed at g7
finance ministers meeting which is a
really quite a significant
moment uh our political backing as the
g7
for an oil price cap on russian oil
which will do two things one
it will prevent putin from profiteering
from the very high oil prices
and equally importantly it will mean
that we will be able to collectively and
we can bring other countries uh as well
that's what we've just agreed amongst
the g7 finance ministers
protect our citizens from oil price
shocks next year
that is a significant step forward we
now have to of course make sure we
implement it
and the strategy is to implement the oil
price cap in december
and then oil price
product cap
in february it will mean that putin
can't profiteer
from excessively high oil prices and of
course protect all of us uh from oil
price shocks next year and beyond
okay let's speak to our business
correspondent paul kelso so paul what
exactly is this cap and how's it going
to work
well this news has just emerged and
picking through the communique that's
been provided by the g7 it's not quite
as simple perhaps as the chancellor made
that sound a price cap on russian oil
makes it sound like there is a price
above which uh countries will not trade
it's not quite that it is more
accurately appears to be a prohibition
on those who enable
the service the trade in oil shipping of
oil particularly maritime trade in oil
so
shipping and
transport companies insurance companies
oil when it's moved has a huge amount of
value so there's insurance required
trading the financing the architecture
of the oil industry it's preventing any
of those services being provided for
russian oil shipments above a certain
price cap so there'll be a number
produced by the g7 in due course it's
not here yet and you won't be able to
trade effectively in russian oil exports
above that number now the intention as
nadine to hardware says out there is to
try and reduce the revenue that russia
is getting from its fossil fuel exports
um all the most of the certainly the
european union the uk many g7 countries
have already committed to reducing their
reliance and their use of russian fossil
fuels the irony of the current situation
in which the reduced supply of russian
fuels has pushed up global energy prices
as we know very dearly in the uk the gas
price particularly has shot up net
effect of that is that while russia is
exporting and finding fewer customers uh
fewer volumes certainly of its oil and
gas it is making greater revenues than
it was before because the price of oil
and gas has got higher and there's a
interesting balance here that's going on
while the eu for the first time eu oil
in
fossil fuel imports from uh russia are
less than 50 for the first time in july
they dropped below that figure they
still make up around two-thirds
of the fossil fuel imports used by eu g7
and nato countries so russian fossil
fuels still vitally important and while
the west the g7 nato are reducing
their imports
china and india particularly are
increasing their imports of russia
russian oil and gas so while russia is
finding the west closed off it has got
new customers and now makes up nearly 25
of china's oil and gas imports and
particularly when you think of the size
of the chinese economy that is fueling
uh the russian war machine in ukraine
even if the west is trying hard not to